today single buscar is on our shrinking
collective paycheck it's streaking as a
share of national income this chart is
from rich clara de the global strategic
advisor over at PIMCO and what you see
here is labor compensation as a share of
national income falling sharply in the
wake of the financial crisis 2009 to
2010 it remains fairly depressed even
though it's come up a little bit at the
end there at the end of 2013 the share
of national income paid to labor round
about the smallest in at least 60 years
now there's a distinction here to be
made Tom and Adam there's labor income
which is wages salaries and benefits
work-related compensation benefits and
then there's capital income which is
investment returns interest dividends so
forth we're talking here about labor
income and how it's fallen in favor of
capital income in the last well I would
argue that that's actually more evidence
of mr. Poquette ease comment remember
the the book that you know I mean it was
summer happen all focused on inequality
well there it is Ellen Ruskin with us
with a Deutsche Bank as well and this is
the great American conundrum that Janet
Yellen will confront an tenian this
morning when does labor get its fair
share oh I don't know about fair share
really but I think the quote the
question is really just when does wage
inflation start to accelerate at least a
little bit do you see any indication of
them um the beginnings really is
starting to see private sector ally
earnings sort of tick up just slightly
and the problem I think their face is
that it's gonna be a slow whole really i
think it's not going to happen anytime
soon and the pass through on to
inflation itself might be slow as well
so it gives the Fed a lot of time to
play well within that and this is an
important distinction deutsche bank has
a set of independent voices peter hooper
and joe lavorgna have arguably the most
optimists to call on the american
economy on Wall Street do you and dr.
Hooper see wage inflation clicking in if
we get a Deutsche Bank economy certainly
forget to say four percent type growth
numbers and we will see that you know I
personally think that three percent gdp
is well within reach we saw for example
leading indicators that came out
yesterday yeah that accelerator were
very consistent with that kind of growth
rate sir I think you will see the
beginnings of this mess i said i think
what you've got here is in technical
terms the Phillips curve is very very
flat the trade off when you
unemployment and slack being used up the
acceleration that you have in wages is
very very slow indeed I should note that
rich clara de wrote that three factors
will determine when and if Labor's share
rebounds in this cycle productivity
growth pricing power and the Fed's
policy rate whatever the face well we
certainly have productivity growth right
some might say it's peaked Yeah right
right exactly again what are the other
two I sink power in the Fed's policy
rate pricing powers I would argue an
alan comment in 30 seconds pricing power
is that the one that's missing here yeah
I don't think it's really pricing power
at this point absolutely